der weg zum eurofighter piloten ist
ehrlicherweise ein langer er dort acht
jahre anfangen wird das ganze mit einer
auswahl die auswahl besteht aus drei
schritten das erste ist die
psychologische und körperliche sprich
medizinische eignungsfeststellung im
heeresspital ist ungefähr zwei wochen
dann nochmal eine ein wichtiges
psychologisches assessment und danach
eine zehnwöchige fliegerische auswahl
testung anschließend fand man in der
grundausbildung auf der b27 hier in
österreich an wird dort einsatz pilot
innerhalb von zwei jahren und bekommt
sämtliche lizenzen die es in der luft
gibt später bewusstgeworden lizenz und
erlernen lizenz anschließend geht man
nach italien wo man auf 339 und auf der
346 auf zwei verschiedenen flugzeugen
auf zwei verschiedenen den strahl
flugzeugen spricht schätzt das fliegen
eines kampfflugzeuges lernt dann geht es
weiter nach deutschland auf die
sogenannte ost die abrechnung erstellen
unit wo man das einfach weiter fliegen
so muss man nach acht jahren ist man
fertig einsatz pilot am system
eurofighter hört sich jetzt lange und
schwer an ist es aber nicht bei uns
bekommt natürlich nichts geschenkt der
weg ist es aber auf jeden fall wert und
kannst du lust hast und gerne mit mir in
der staffel im eurofighter fliegen
möchte ist dann melde dich beim
bundesheer zum piloten denn das
eurofighter fliegen beim bundesheer ist
der geist denn es geht das geld und ich
würde mich jeden tag wieder dafür
entscheiden